I use geography everyday in everyway
I'd like to know where on the planet I
am I'm Sylvia Earle I'm an oceanographer
and explorer-in-residence at the
National Geographic I've been a
geography enthusiast since I was a
little kid and geography has been really
important to me because I'm a mountain
climber and a sailor my name is Rick
Ridgeway and I run the environmental
programs at the outdoor clothing company
Patagonia geographies is very close to
my heart because I need it for what I do
exploring and go from country to country
you need to know where the countries are
how I get there and how I get across the
ocean I'm Molly Hicks I'm an ocean
brewer and an adventurer in October I'll
be leaving for 18 months to row around
the world geography is knowing where you
are knowing the terrain knowing the
nature of things
geography gives you a sense of place not
just for where you are but where
everything else on the planet actually
is geography is an incredibly important
subject to everyone especially kids
because it cements everything else you
know it connects everyone in the whole
planet together where am I
relative to all of the mountains the
rivers the cities you don't have a grasp
of geography you can't connect the dots
you can't learn history you can't learn
physics without the geography to glue it
all together
geography is essential if you're going
to know where the mountains are and what
they look like and how to climb them
ever since I was a child I have loved
maps when I first heard that there was
an electronic means of being able to see
the world to spin it around to start
high in the sky and then zoom in to
see your backyard or your neighbor's
backyard or to fly through the Grand
Canyon trophy is extremely important to
me because of what I do I row from one
country across the nation to another
country and in this particular
expedition I'm running around the world
and so I need to know where I'm leaving
from how I gonna get to the other side
so geography and mapping is incredibly
important to what I do when I was only
14 years old I wanted to be a mountain
climber and I became a mountain climber
to do that I needed to know about the
mountains where they were how high they
were what they look like
geography taught me that and it's been a
really important part of my life as an
oceanographer and Explorer I've had the
joy of living underwater that is where
you go and stay in a little underwater
laboratory I've gone to the average
depth of the ocean about the same depth
of the Titanic is on the seafloor
but now when your cell phone on your
laptop on your desktop you can be
connected you two can go diving even if
it is without getting wet
you